so this government is not
going to raise the rates of income tax
national insurance
or v.a.t instead
our first step is to freeze personal tax
thresholds
we've nearly doubled the income tax
personal allowance over the last decade
making it the most generous of any g20
country
we will of course deliver our promise to
increase it again
next year to twelve thousand five
hundred and seventy pounds
but we will then keep it at this more
generous level
until april twenty twenty six the higher
rate threshold
will similarly be increased next year to
50 000 pounds 270
and will then also remain at that level
for the same period
nobody's take home pay will be less than
it is now
as a result of this policy but i want to
be clear
with all members that this policy does
remove
the incremental benefit created had
thresholds continued
to increase with inflation we are not
hiding it
i am here explaining it to the house and
it is in the budget document
in black and white it is a
tax policy that is progressive and fair
and i will also maintain at their
current levels until april 2026
the inheritance tax thresholds the
pensions lifetime allowance
the annual exempt amount in capital
gains tax and for two years from april
2022 the vat registration threshold
which at 85 000 pounds will remain more
than twice
as generous as the eu and oecd averages
we'll also tackle fraud in our covid
schemes with a hundred million pounds
to set up a new hmrc task force of
around a thousand investigators
as well as new measures and new
investment in hmrc
to clamp down on tax avoidance and
evasion the full details are set
out in the red book madam deputy speaker
the government is providing businesses
with over a hundred
billion pounds of support to get through
this pandemic
so it is fair and necessary to ask them
to contribute to our recovery so the
second step
i am taking today is that in 2023
the rate of corporation tax paid on
company profits
will increase to 25
even after this change the united
kingdom
will still have the lowest corporation
tax rate
in the g7 lower than the united states
canada italy japan germany
and france we're also introducing
some crucial protections first
this new higher rate won't take effect
until april 2023
well after the point when the obr expect
the economy
to have recovered and even then
because corporation tax is only charged
on company profits
any struggling business will by
definition be
unaffected second
i'm protecting small businesses with
profits of fifty thousand pounds or less
by creating a small profits rate
maintained at the current rate
of 19 this means
around 70 of companies
1.4 million businesses will be
completely
unaffected and third
we will introduce a taper above 50 000
so that only businesses with profits of
a quarter of a million pounds or greater
will be taxed at the full 25 rate
that means only 10 of companies
will pay the full higher rate
so yes it's a tax rise on company
profits
but only on the larger more profitable
companies
and only in two years time
and i wanted to announce this now
because i think
for business certainty matters
for the next two years i'm also
making the tax treatment of losses
significantly
more generous by allowing businesses to
carry back losses of up to two million
pounds
for three years providing a significant
cash flow benefit this means companies
can now claim
additional tax refunds of up to seven
hundred and sixty thousand pounds
and because of the current eight percent
bank surcharge
the implied overall tax rate for banks
would be
too high so we will review the surcharge
to make sure the combined rate of tax on
the uk banking sector
doesn't increase significantly from its
current level
and to make sure this important industry
remains internationally
competitive